once again I'd be fun to show you some  New Year's resolutions that were made by  people right here in our studio audience  for example this person's resolution  right here yeah write a book about being  kicked out of ZZ Top and sent to prison  well this one really focus on my new  business shroom hats dot biz here's one  published memoir my life as Libya's Moby  look at this crawl out of a TV set in a  Japanese ghost movie tracked down my  first true love Bernhard and let him  know I still think he's an [ __ ]  capture a cricket in my home with a  handmade ceramic tea cup and gently  place it out  try to remember being good at geometry  does not equal being good at haircut let  Conan know he's a dead man if he even  thinks about making fun of me in this  comedy good  [Music]  you